Ponce de Leon was way off.
The fountain of youth is clearly in Japan.
What's up everybody? I'm Patrick Jones. This is your Buzz 60.
70-year-old equestrian Hiroshi Hoketsu has qualified for the London Olympics.
He's made Olympic appearances before in '64 and '88, and was the oldest Olympian in Beijing in 2008.
If Japan sends Hoketsu this summer, he'll again have that honor at the ripe age of 71.
However, that won't make him the oldest Olympian ever.
That honor goes to Oscar Swahn of Sweden, who competed in the 1920 single shot running deer rifle event at the age of 72.
Hoketsu hasn't seen too much success in the Games,...
...but he comes from a country that honors their elders and doesn't have this mentality.
Hey, I guess they're right. Senior citizens, although slow and dangerous behind the wheel, can still serve a purpose.
I'll be right back.
Don't you go dying on me!
That's success enough.
Buzz 60. Now you know, pass it on.